[Music]
when it comes to anomalous religions the
scp foundation is no stranger to them
the weird wild and utterly
incomprehensible belief systems that
populate the world of the anomalous
might seem too crazy and dangerous to
participate in on paper but if there's
anything that brings people together
it's the power of faith and belief take
for example the mechanites a massive
religious following with various sects
located across the globe united in their
belief that body modification using
technology is the pathway to worship
their god meccan the broken god who will
one day reassemble the lost parts of its
body and usher the universe into a new
age of technological superiority
or the cult-like children of the scarlet
king who worship a brutal ancient entity
known as the scarlet king who exists as
a dangerous idea unable to be accurately
described or catalogued by contemporary
science separating the ages of modernity
and antiquity and invigorating its
followers to commit horrible acts in the
name of their king but if you're a
long-time viewer of scp explained then
chances are you've heard of the broken
god and the scarlet king arguably two of
the most popular anomalous religions so
today we're going to be talking about
one that you might not have heard about
fifthism fithism is a lot more difficult
to explain because instead of a central
prevailing deity and strict belief
system that unites fittists the religion
is defined more by its nonsensical
illogical and absurd state of mind that
it imposes on its followers fithism is
all-consuming a mindset that is often
transmitted through mimetic means such
as books that contain rambling
paragraphs of surreal imagery and
platitudes that are dispersed among
unsuspecting populations by fitthists
those who read fithis literature often
succumb to fithis beliefs themselves
losing their mind and delving into a
strange world centered around cosmic
starfish and the number five where
nothing makes sense but it doesn't
matter because you've now been
enlightened and to the fifthist zealot
it all makes sense the foundation had to
deal with a dangerous piece of fithis
literature in the past
scp-1425 the book titled star signals
was a self-help book with mimetic
properties that nearly consumed the
minds of the entire world becoming a
national bestseller that forced the
foundation to take extreme measures to
purge it from public knowledge and
destroy every remaining copy just listen
to this excerpt from scp-1425
which illustrates the strange
mind-altering fithis doctrine now
imagine that the place where your
desires are made real has a name
it's called the fifth world the fifth
world is the cosmos twisted around you
into the shape you will wish for it has
never been but you can make it so if the
current world is like a tight collared
suit then the fifth world is like a
flowing robe that allows complete
freedom of movement you will never truly
move before you move in the fifth world
you'll feel like a square on a piece of
paper who was only just made about up
and down when dealing with fitism that's
the kind of strangeness you're
guaranteed to encounter the foundation's
operation to get scp-1425
under control took weeks and didn't work
out as smoothly as they hoped proving
the religion as a force to be reckoned
with and definitely not one to take
lightly but the story of star signals
scp-1425 is one for another day now that
you have a crash course in fifthism we
can get to the real reason you're here
scp-2456 dreams of a broken world what
exactly is scp-2456
well if you guessed that it's fittest
you would be correct but considering
what we know about fitism that could
mean anything
scp-2456 discovery dates back to a
foundation operation in eugene oregon
where foundation operatives raided the
hideout of individuals belonging to the
serpent's hand a paramilitary resistance
organization united by their belief that
the world should embrace the anomalous
the serpent's hand has been heavily
critical of groups like the global
occult coalition and the scp foundation
their containment and especially their
destruction of anomalous objects and
entities in an ideal world for a member
of the hand anomalies coexist with the
world we know it's an idealistic picture
but their antagonism against the
foundation has painted a serious target
on their back subjecting them to
frequent ambushes and raids on their
hideouts and that's exactly what
happened inside the abandoned warehouse
where
scp-2456 was discovered the foundation
sent a highly trained mobile task force
a squad named bookworms after one of the
remaining copies of scp-1425
the fifthist self-help book star signals
which was supposedly stowed away inside
the warehouse upon entry the operative
stumbled upon a serpent's hand hideout
and a firefight between hand members and
foundation operatives ensued the task
force suffered minor casualties but they
managed to secure a hold over the
warehouse after a brief struggle inside
they not only found a copy of star
signals but several other anomalous
artifacts that the hand was using to
further its goals during the inventory
another curious object was found a
wooden crate with a label that read
fifth cycle of the mind stamped onto its
side when open the foundation uncovered
dozens more copies of star signals as
well as numerous other fithis texts and
a weathered note signed by an unknown
individual that read george this is our
latest catch please burn these as soon
as you can at your discretion don't let
the idiots find this at the very bottom
of the crate several manuscripts were
discovered that contained information
about a then unknown fittest anomaly
involving a strange variation of the
belief system which the foundation
immediately began researching the
manuscripts pointed towards the
existence of an abstract theology that
has existed for centuries that when
preached by its believers transmits a
memetic virus this religion is varying
in characteristics but is
distinguishable by several qualities
such as starting out as a variation of
an existing theology making frequent use
of the number 5 in its written doctrine
and revolving around godhead figures
that are synonymous with the sun who are
believed to bring about a future
apocalypse on top of those written works
make mention of a non-existent sea
frequent references to celestial objects
the appearance of hands as a religious
symbol and the belief that the sun has
great mathematical significance and
importance if all that sounds confusing
to you congratulations you're immune to
fithism if it sounds appealing well you
might just be affected by scp-2456
scp-2456 is a memetic parasite
transmitted from one person to another
by being exposed to the theology we
described above which the foundation
labeled scp-2456-1
those affected by
scp-2456 show an affinity towards
astrology astronomy and pseudoscience in
general as well as an increased
proficiency in speaking foreign
languages there's also prolonged
episodes of psychosis paranoia and
disassociative identity disorder as well
as a high attention span for geometrical
shapes patterns and sequences involving
you guessed it the number five usually
the scp-2456 parasite will remain
dormant for a period of time but once
activated by several stress triggers the
subject afflicted with the anomaly will
undergo a mind-altering revelation
falling asleep for a period of three to
four days experiencing vivid cryptic
dreams involving religious prophets and
figures from various theologies being
executed one by one with a sword and
celestial bodies dancing in the sky
after this long rest the subject will
begin preaching the dash one religion to
others causing the parasite to transmit
from one person to another bringing more
and more followers to its cause and
after that the cycle will repeat more
followers are attracted more begin
preaching and before you can realize
scp-2456 has affected a large group of
the foundation with such an easily
transmissible anomaly it's a wonder the
world hadn't been taken over by
scp-2456 a long time ago but when you
consider that fittism is already an
established belief system maybe in a way
it already has believers in the religion
that those affected by scp-2456
preach are incredibly violent and
aggressive with their strong feelings
growing more and more with every new
iteration of the religion over time
believers usually seek out those who
haven't been affected by scp-2456
an attempt to spread the religion and if
they refuse murder them but the
foundation's research has shown that no
individual that has been affected by
scp-2456
has ever been successful in inflicting
more than five percent of the existing
human population chalk it up to luck
because foundation simulations have
indicated that a ck-class end of the
world scenario would occur if
scp-2456 infection rates exceed over
seven percent if you can't tell that's
pretty bad not only that but the
foundation discovered that as the
religion evolves over time it creates a
minor reality warping effect and if left
unchecked can fracture the integrity of
space and time at a high enough level
thankfully the foundation has one way to
combat scp-2456
during the period of time directly after
an individual wakes up from their
prophetic sleep treating them with
high-class amnestics has been discovered
to completely rid the individual of the
scp-2456 parasite bringing them back to
their senses but still due to the
memetic nature and the high number of
suspected infected individuals the
foundation has found that complete
containment of scp-2456
is not physically possible at least with
the organization's current technology
level still that isn't stopping
researchers from working tirelessly
trying to develop methods of
neutralizing all instances of the
parasite in the wild taking the fight to
the internet and making sure that their
web crawlers can quickly scan for
keywords related to scp-2456
on websites and social media databases
if they're found the foundation can
quickly trace posts to whoever wrote
them and bring them to a secure facility
for further research it's never clean
work having to abduct civilians from
their homes but in this case given how
dangerous
scp-2456 can be if left unchecked it
might be justified but how has the
religion that
scp-2456 instills in its victims
scp-2456-1 evolved over the years the
manuscripts that the foundation
uncovered inside the serpent's hand
hideaway detailed six variations of the
theology over time let's take a look at
them the first variation dates all the
way back to 1837
a religion by the name of the
god-worshipping society which was a
fusion of confucianism and catholicism
that cropped up in china at the time
spread by hong xiu kwan a chinese
revolutionary who led the taiping army
in rebellion against the qing dynasty
the stress of having to deal with the
political instability of the era
resulted in
scp-2456 triggering inside yukuan's mind
and causing him to preach his variation
of the d-1 religion to his followers
this furthered the strength of the
taiping army allowing them to march
through nearly every province of china
in retaliation until they achieve their
goal some accounts of zhukon's followers
recount them transforming into piles of
geological matter which the foundation
found dna evidence bonded to sediment in
pockets of igneous rock in the area
undoubtedly a result of scp-2456
reality warping side effects the second
variation was found in ancient egypt
under the name of the cult of aten the
progenitor of this variation is unknown
due to how far back it dates but the
person who imposed the will of the cult
of a-10 the most was then pharaoh a
kenneth of amarna who used his power as
head of state to condemn worship of all
egyptian deities other than aten the
cult of aten's reign over egypt resulted
in several reality altering properties
including strange behavior of celestial
bodies feelings of stretched out
unending days and the refusal of the sun
to set for five days which resulted in a
drought along the bank of the nile
egyptian star charts from this time
display star systems constellations and
nebulae that do not exist or are
depicted incorrectly the most prominent
of these changes include the inclusion
of a planet named nubu which is
described as half of the size of venus
that would pulsate with light in 5
second intervals there's that number
again the third variation jumps to the
time of the aztecs and while little is
known about its origins its impact on
aztec society was enormous the aztec
deity tonatiuh was said to be the fifth
sun that set in the sky the aztecs
frequently made sacrifices to tanatia
and the worship of the entity caused a
reality warping effect throughout the
empire the sun and the moon were
eclipsed by unknown celestial objects
consistently for weeks bodies from past
sacrifices would reanimate and attack
civilians reaching into their throats
and pulling out their hearts the coasts
of the empire suffered from glowing red
poisons which killed off fish and caused
tissue necrosis in humans as well as
forming large blood clots in the lungs
the fourth variation the cult of the
supreme being was a short-lived religion
perpetrated by french philosopher
augustine robespierre during the time of
the french revolution its small
longevity meant that the religion didn't
garner enough followers to cause intense
reality warping effects but some
anomalous characteristics were still
prevalent such as reports of incorporeal
manifestations in the streets of paris
dimensional shifts in saloons and
smoking parlors around the city and the
increased brutality and ruthlessness of
the revolutionaries who imposed a large
daily quota of executions the fifth
variation is entirely unknown most
likely to do with the numbers
significance to the fithis belief system
attempts to access the scp foundation
files on the fifth incarnation of
scp-2456-1's belief system are met with
failure as the file's data is corrupted
this however raises a new question maybe
this unknown religion is still one
that's active today maybe the fifth
variation of scp-2456-1
is fifth-ism itself having evolved as a
variation of
scp-2456 over the years that would add a
whole new level of danger to fithism as
if it got out of hand the
reality-warping effects of being a
scp-2456-based theology would cause
destruction to the fabric of reality
itself the sixth variation is similar to
the fifth with its files being similarly
corrupted in the foundation's databases
and all information on it being entirely
unknown say for a single readable
sentence which states that the main
perpetrator the prophet of the sixth
variation of scp-2456-1
is still at large today remaining a
threat to the world knowing that this
virus can affect large swaths of the
population as it did in the aztec and
egyptian empires the foundation remains
extremely cautious of scp-2456
especially with the added risk of
fittism being prevalent in the anomalous
world and the unknown sixth religion
still at large also discovered inside
the serpent's hand warehouse were
several manuscripts from the various
religions that scp-2456
influenced scriptures from the cult of
aten letters written by robespierre in
his journal and even a text from the
taiping revolution labeled the wisdoms
of the heavenly king but what did they
say the text source from china describes
the story of a prophet who wanted to
bring great knowledge to the people
beneath him and so as the text describes
he followed the smoke a fitness metaphor
for reaching enlightenment he did so by
studying alongside a mentor for five
months and on the fifth day of the fifth
month he had achieved enlightenment and
knew he had a great mission to complete
he roused his subjects rallying the
people who lived in ash and filth to war
attacking with the power of the sun on
their side those who face the prophet
ran but the ones who were left
understood on the fifth day they turned
into tar sand and salt and the prophet
remained victorious sound familiar it's
an abridged retelling of hong-ji quan's
revolution the rest of the text
describes a parable of a master and a
student philosophizing about the stars
with a particular poem that stands out
it reads five spokes of a broken star
five elements that forever spar
five senses to evoke the mind five
pieces slowly unwind a black moon
howling is a vision unworthy of one's
sight a hymn source from the cult of 18
also makes references to the number 5
and specifically makes mention of the
black moon if you're familiar with the
scp foundation's inner circle the
overseer council then you know that they
frequently use the phrase does the black
moon howl as a security measure to
access top secret confidential documents
its true meaning however remains
shrouded in mystery but here you see it
connected to scp-2456
it can't be a coincidence robespierre's
diary describes an account of the french
revolution detailing robespierre's
descent into madness that led to the
creation of the short-lived cult of the
supreme being the revolution descends
into brutality and as robespierre
describes the streets run pink with
blood and agony as the cult revels in
the bloodshed and ruthlessness all of
this points to a compelling mystery
about the true nature of
scp-2456 especially with the connection
to the commonly used symbol of the black
moon in the scp foundation and all of
this came to a head on december 21 2016
when an unidentifiable audiophile was
sent to a foundation researcher that
alerted the server's firewalls the
audiophile was traced as originating
from a cubicle that had been vacant for
six years with hardware that had been
short-circuited and badly corroded a
portion of the audio file was recovered
from the damaged terminal and the
foundation quickly began to transcribe
it it was the voice of an unknown
foundation employee who detailed that he
had been working with the organization
for two decades and that while he had
seen horrible things in the past as he
was recording this message he was more
terrified than ever before he was
assigned to research scp-2456
cataloging all the past occurrences of
the various religions that had cropped
up as a result of the parasite over the
years he had experience in mimetics but
the danger of researching
scp-2456 was proving difficult to
contend with members of the research
team were succumbing to scp-2456
but not only that they were disappearing
too after one personnel was admitted to
an infirmary the speaker recounted that
he would never be able to find them
again the audio continued to play and
the speaker explained that scp-2456
also carries a potent anti-meme an idea
that causes dramatic reality shifts
often characterized by something being
imperceptible and unrecognizable to the
human brain whenever information about
an
scp-2456 religion is read or written
about the anti-meme will enter the
subject and slowly erase them from
existence alongside all records and
knowledge about the subject sometimes
however corpses and names remain the
speaker detailed how he witnessed his
peers slowly disappear as the file goes
on he descends into typical 5thist
ranting speaking about fives following
the smoke and a dream but he leaves a
terrifying message the foundation is old
but the world is older maybe the
serpent's hand with their manuscripts
and research on
scp-2456 were attempting to keep the
forces of the fifth king a mysterious
deity the man mentions at bay now inside
the hands of the foundation these
documents will never be destroyed they
will continue to be read and continue to
linger in reality the speaker signs off
ranting more about the star signals
incident and the fifth stream that
permeates the shadows of all reality as
the speaker states once history is
forgotten it is of course doomed to
repeat itself and the sixth cycle will
forevermore echo now go check out
scp-001 the broken god or boro cycle and
children of scp-001 the scarlet king is
scp-999 really his son for more
anomalous religions and their bizarre
followers from scp explained